this is the challenge of a youtuber
which is
uh you know pushing that record button
and actually filming something because
you never know
are people gonna hate it or you know is
it good enough uh have you thought
through what you're gonna say i have not
thought through what i'm gonna say
okay so um i wanna talk about the
question
of why is it that right now
when it is really easy to get access to
facts and information where you can just
pull up your phone and look up anything
in the world
why is it now that we have the most
access to facts
do facts mean the least
this is what i want to know why does
fake news spread now
why are we more polarized now than ever
before
and what i have to kind of admit to you
is that
i was a real optimist
maybe i was naive about the internet but
my
thinking about having an international
communication system
whereby anyone anywhere can share
anything and
anyone anywhere regardless of say their
education background or their class
standing can get access to
real information through wikipedia okay
my thinking was the
internet was going to make everyone
happier
and more informed more educated
uh and and probably more tolerant of
others around them
and the reason why i think that the
internet should make people more
tolerant
is because it should expose people to
people who are not like them
right i mean is this is this crazy
my thinking is that like as we have a
platform to communicate with each other
people in diverse places people with
different interests from us
uh and we all have the ability to sort
of debate and agree upon what is true
we all would become more accepting of
the facts maybe i'm ranting on about
this too much is this too much
okay so we can edit we can edit so
i guess the point is in summary
i thought that the um i thought that the
internet would make
the world more connected more tolerant
more educated and more true
like more agreed upon the facts and the
way things are
and for a while i think there were signs
that this was happening
there was the arab spring where you know
people in countries that had been kind
of dictatorships or people who've been
oppressed were rising up there was the
approval of
gay marriage in a number of countries
there were agreed upon uh climate
agreements
uh that seemed to suggest the whole
international community was coming
together
there are things like my youtube channel
where there can be
four million people who can watch
or subscribe to a channel that's about
information and about learning new
things about the universe
right the whole rise of smart content on
youtube
i took as an indication that things were
going in the right direction
that here we can get communities
together
uh who are all interested in the same
sort of
in the same
quite high level phenomena you know the
same
like if i made a tv show i could never
convince anyone to
uh make a an episode about
interpretations of quantum mechanics
i could never convince someone to make a
video about pilot wave theory and go
in as much depth as i went into in my
videos but
on the internet you can find that
audience because
you can aggregate across the whole world
so little niche audiences across every
country can all come together and say
you know we want to learn this and we
can support
this sort of enterprise you guys in
agreement
okay now here's the problem what i
didn't think about
was that other communities can form
communities where people have particular
agendas ideological or religious
or you know people with extreme biases
normally they're not much of a force to
reckon with because
they are dilute in our populations but
on the internet
just like the people who love physics
people who hate
science or uh people with with differing
ideologies and people who are intolerant
can find each other and they can come
together
into these camps so i think that starts
to suggest
why we have the problem that we have
today
and then what do people do once they've
found their communities once they've
found their people
well we have meetups but we also we
share things with each other
online and you can think about some
communities that are really innocuous
like
the communities of people who are cat
lovers who love sharing
like pictures of kittens and then
someone gets the idea to write like a
really cute phrase like i can has
cheeseburger
on a picture of a kitten and then that
little image
tickles our brains in a way that is
really strong and really incredible and
then that spreads throughout the
internet
and what you have in essence is kind of
evolution taking place and evolution of
ideas
on the internet and so i guess what i
mean is
you know one person can post this
picture of a cat and then people can
vary the phrases that are on it
and the the best phrase is going to win
out and get itself
replicated and shared across the web
more than any other
and the same thing happens with
ideological arguments
right if there's some sort of debate
that's happening on the internet
different versions
of arguments can pop up
and when you think about two groups on
the internet debating
they're not really debating each other
each
community creates what they think the
opponent's argument is and then people
within that community can tweak that
argument to make it
worse and worse and worse to make it the
the most
awful version of itself that pushes our
buttons and when it pushes our buttons
then we share it with everyone we know
and we say look at what the other side
is talking about look at how
how awful it is and and we keep evolving
the ideas
to make them really really bad those are
the ones that get shared and spread just
like
in evolution we are evolving arguments
to make them the worst form of
themselves and then to make the
the pushback you know even worse
and that i think is leading to this
polarization
and what's worse the internet is
organized by algorithms
algorithms that are designed to take the
things
that are most engaged with
most that that most push our buttons
that get us going and get us sharing and
liking or hating
and they promote those even further
and this i think is where something like
fake news comes in
how is it possible that during the last
election cycle in the u.s
more fake news was spread and shared
than real news
that is extraordinary and i think it
happens
because the internet allows groups of
people to come together
who have really particular views it
allows them to share things with each
other
even sharing what they think the
opponent's argument is
tweaking it ever so slightly doing all
of these little mutations little
alterations and finding the ones
that push our buttons the most and then
those are the ones that get shared
those are the ones that get liked and
hated and everything
and those are the ones the algorithm
elevates to the very top
so rather than rather than the internet
bringing us together rather than us
converging around the facts instead the
internet allows us to
divide ourselves into factions and to
have this crazy evolution of arguments
which is
facilitated by the algorithms pushing us
ever
further apart
and that is the the the best that i've
been able to reason
about why we now care less about facts
than we ever did before
because deep down each one of us
is based on confirmation bias
we naturally go out into our world and
we seek things that agree with what we
think
rather than looking for things that
disagree with what we think
that's an innate human trait as you can
see in my video can you solve this
so it's upsetting and uh i think we need
to find a way to overcome this division
and
find a way to agree again on what is
truth
and what is not thank you
all right all right so uh questions
anyone want a question or comment we
have a gentleman down the front yes um
you know that term has a word cyber
balkanization i learned it
from visas very useful term say it again
cyber vulcanization falconization
balconization yeah sort of the split the
splinter net you know everything sort of
the splinter net i love it
cyber balkanization i don't know what
balkanization is
i guess that's the political situation
in the balkans at some point
oh cyber bulkinization
yeah shout out to cgp grey's video here
because he has this idea that
you should try you should think of your
opinions
like papers in a box and if you find
another opinion that is better than
the opinion that you have in the box you
should swedish switches out
you should not believe us you are not
your opinions your opinions are just
like stuff you carry with you
and that should be easily changed it's a
very good point
i also i should cite cgp grey's video
about the evolution of ideas because i
was strongly influenced by that video i
think it's one of his
his best and most important videos yes
um
so we had his mechanics that evolved
strong ideas that
polarize people do you think there's a
way to utilize this a
mechanic to make the internet better to
bring us all together
to not being pushed around but it by
utilizing it to
better stuff right i mean i personally
think that
the mechanics that's brought us here to
division
is not in its current form going to lead
us to convergence
so i think something has to change about
the mechanics and if i think about one
of these options right who is uh
saying about the ideas that being the
paper and you should really swap them
out that's a very sophisticated mature
idea
right it's very sophisticated and mature
to think that we can
have our beliefs set down and then when
they get challenged we can
think about them and and swap them out
for new ones that's not something that
humans like to do
it's hard it's hard i was um
recently in the netherlands and the guy
who was driving this van we were going
around shooting a tv series guy was
driving the van
talk to me about electric cars
and he was saying to me derek you know
that even if you get like a low
emissions or a zero emissions car an
electric car
half of the emissions of any vehicle
come from the production of the vehicle
in the first place
so really if you think you're cutting
down a lot of the emissions of your
vehicle by getting an electric car
which full disclosure i do have uh
he is saying you're you're not really
you know dramatically decreasing the
emissions because still half the
emissions happen
when the car was made so a better
strategy than
buying all electric cars would be to not
buy any cars at all and just keep
driving your cars a few years longer
because that's going to save a lot more
because
you know a lot of the waste is up front
and i did not believe him
i was like that's crazy half the
emissions half like i know it's hard to
make a car but
half the emissions and you think it's
gonna drive for you know hundreds
hundreds of thousands of kilometers and
i went and i looked it up
and it was true and i take his piece of
paper
and i swap it in and i move mine out
but i think it's a really hard thing to
do and it's something that like i felt
repulsed by like i didn't want to swap
my piece of paper out
that's why i think i don't know that
that can be the solution
wholesale because we can't just say to
everyone hang on a lot of you have
beliefs that are not true
can we just swap some paper out with you
they'll say no
that's my paper um so i was gonna say
to me the thing that needs to change i
would say is some of the systems and
particularly the algorithm algorithms
because i think facebook and i think
they are looking at this now
needs to figure out a way not to elevate
fake news but to let it languish
and promote real news they have a
responsibility because they are curating
the feeds
of a billion people around the world
they have the responsibility to make
sure those feeds
are not misleading and that is something
that they were um
bad about doing in the last uh last
election
yep if you're uh determined to find the
real news you
go out on a marathon of research and
usually you dig deeper and deeper past
the sort of junk that's being catered to
us by the algorithms
but what you're essentially proposing is
some sort of a lie detector
to be implemented in algorithms that's
kind of hard to do
right unless it's manually altered
companies on facebook i don't think you
can manually alter the algorithm i think
you have to find a way and i think the
algorithms can be made i think it's a
big challenge i agree with you
but i think there's a way to do it i
mean if you look at google search
results
there's constantly people trying to game
what google's doing
but you don't end up with fake news
sites at the top you don't end up with
spam sites coming up top in the google
search results
that's because they battled and battled
in battle to find these signals
that that separate what's a valuable
site what's a site that people
appreciate and and seems to be
linked into a whole bunch of other sites
which are all part of a factual web
right and i think that similarly
facebook needs to do something like that
where in essence they look for signals
of truth
i agree very hard and it's going to be a
constant battle
but i think you need to look for the
signal of truth rather than just the
signal of what pushes people's buttons
because i yep like if you look back at
like the stone age
if you had a weird opinion and you were
in your little tribe
either you convinced everyone or you
changed your mind right
so you know facebook is kind of like our
tribe right so some people use facebook
as more like oh these are my
acquaintances but a lot of people use it
like these are my close friends
and if a close friend says something
weird about something on facebook
you comment right you have a discussion
and you know you don't say no you're
wrong
i'm not gonna talk to you anymore right
because he's your friend so either you
change your mind or you convince the
other person right
but if you go on like reddit you're not
gonna convince like
10 million billion people so uh
yeah i don't know maybe like if you've
ever like tried the controversial tab on
reddit
that's usually where some of the most
interesting discussions are but
yeah sometimes it's not so fun and uh i
think this brings
me to one of my kind of points that i
think is a little bit counterintuitive
and it's a point that's difficult for me
to think about i i'm still not
settled on this idea but i wonder if
sometimes that
arguing just makes things worse you know
as someone who makes
science films i wonder like if i go out
make a film about something
that's controversial i don't know if
maybe i'm just making it worse and so i
i think we all have to think about that
really carefully before we engage in
discussions
which is is there a chance by making
these points which you think are really
clear and really get at the truth
is it possible that you were just
causing the other um
side to be more deeply entrenched in
their beliefs in the first place
down here yep do you think that adapting
algorithms
to like identify true statements
can have some issues with like
separating true
or like uncontrollable statements from
controversial that um what's
uncontroversial
will more likely seem true yeah
i get you there i as i say i don't know
the solution
i think it is hard but i do think we
have to figure it out
i think that there are places on the web
that have
a good record of truth wikipedia for
example for all of its ability to be
edited
is still more likely than not to be true
so i think there's all these places
that do signal true things i think you
know cnn
is more likely to be true than breitbart
news so i mean
there has got to be some signal in the
noise some way to
trace back references and things right
some of the things we talked about were
um
some of the things we talked about were
manual intervention or or
deeply searching right going back and
looking at all these different sources
that's something that most humans don't
do and won't do
and can't do don't have the time to do
that's why i'm saying a machine
can look at references a machine can
look
at uh signals that spread you know and
they can do that very rapidly so you
want to find out who are these people do
they have a record of
you know false are they actually
accredited are they at a university
there's there's a variety of things that
you can do
to see whether things have have a
true signal or not i don't think it's
easy but i think it's possible yes
there are traditional news medias that
may
present the news or these articles
fake or not to the public don't you
think
they sort of have part of the
blame because they fact checked
those fake articles when the results
already were in
like all these statements were
said and then when the results were in
say in the last election they just went
oh wait these statements were they true
oh wait they weren't but too late to
alter
the results from false statements yeah
but i think there was a lot of live
fact-checking but it didn't seem to do
anything like people didn't seem to care
about facts
and that deep down is the is the real
question i want to get the answer to
which is like why don't people seem to
care what's true and i guess
maybe rather than putting it that way
there were different camps
which each had their own narratives and
their own things that they believed was
true and that was different from the
other
side and so figuring out what true was
was
was really hard especially if you were
completely in one camp
i mean there were there were fake things
around on both sides